bonsoir à tous ravis de vous retrouver à
la une de ça vous regarde ce soir sueurs
froides pour l'économie mondiale
l'épidémie de coronavirus révèle notre
hiver dépendance à la chine
les chaînes d'approvisionnement
industrielle commence à être menacée
notamment dans les secteurs de
l'automobile ou encore de la santé alors
quand l'usiné du monde quand l'atelier
du monde est à l'arrêt faut-il repenser
nos systèmes de production
c'est la question du grand débat ce soir
la guerre des nerfs sur les retraites
dont l'hémicycle les esprits
s'échauffent le ton monte et le
rapporteur se lâche
retour sur une nuit d'invectivés à
l'assemblée dans la deuxième partie de
cette émission le premier ministre
demande à ses troupes de tenir encore un
petit peu mais les députés de la
majorité en sont ils capables nous
poserons la question rapporteur licola
turquois et puis notre grand témoin ce
soir et depuis des années notre meilleur
ambassadeur de france en chine il est de
tous les voyages officiels
à pékin il est même devenu le
représentant spécial pour le quai
d'orsay de ce pays la chine
l'ancien premier ministre jean pierre
raffarin est avec nous ce soir voilà
donc pour le programme c'est parti
hashed accès vers n'oubliez pas on y va
[Musique]
et bienvenue à vous chers
téléspectateurs merci d'avoir choisi lcp
nos invités en plateau ce soir jean
pierre raffarin bonsoir bonsoir primaire
tous d'être notre grand témoin on a une
heure à passer ensemble balayé les
grands sujets de l'actualité
on va parler de ce 49 3 qui semble
devenu inévitable sur les retraites on
dire un mot des municipales qui risque
d'être un peu difficile pour la majorité
présidentielle que vous soutenez je
rappelle que vous avez quitté les
républicains mais on va surtout parler
de cette crise du coronavirus avec cette
question ce soit le monde et y
économiquement trop dépendants de la
chine on en parle avec vous brendan
bonsoir vous êtes député la république
en marche de paris et vous présidez le
groupe d'amitié france chine à
l'assemblée bienvenue à vous lucile
schmid bonsoir vous êtes à présidente du
think tank la fabrique écologique afin
fabrice le sachet bienvenus vous êtes
vice président et porte parole du medef
merci à tous les quatre de participer à
ce ça vous regarde en direct je vous
donne la parole dans un instant mais si
j'ai bien compris on n'a rien sans la
chine 7 billets stéphane stéphane
blakowski que l'on accueille tout de
suite
[Musique]
on sent les dames bonsoir messieurs
bonsoir stéphane si j'ai bien compris ce
sport si j'ai bien compris à myriam la
france s'est découvert une maladie
encore plus grave que le coronavirus
malheureusement ce sont des choses qui
arrivent on va chez le médecin on a une
petite douleur qui nous inquiète on fait
un examen et en fait ça s'avère beaucoup
plus grave que prévu mais là c'est un
peu pareil c'est à dire que on est tous
inquiet à l'idée date rappelle
coronavirus de sentir quelqu'un qui tous
autour du loup en fait la france est
atteinte d'une maladie beaucoup plus
grave
là si nos dépendances là si nos
dépendances
c'est quoi cette maladie comment ça vous
savez pas ce que c'est on est tous
atteints dans ce studio de sinnoh
dépendance alors je tombe par jean
pierre raffarin qui lui est carrément je
vous explique bercy le dépendance s'est
contenté tellement dépendants de la
chine qu'on peut plus s'en passer dans
la vie donc jean pierre raffarin 8
amoureux de la chine donc c'est l'état
de dépendance ultime on est amoureux
c'est le stade le plus avancé de la
maladie d'ailleurs séquence émotion
regarder on va voir notre ancien premier
ministre avec xi jingping une pub
président chinois
vous avez reçu la médaille de l'amitié
mais bon nous on est dépendant aussi ce
n'est même pas pour une noble cause on
n'est pas dépendant par amour ou par
amitié
on est dépendant de la chine parce qu'on
n'a pas le choix myriam comme ça on
appelle choix ballon on n'a pas le choix
vous l'avais dit dans votre lancement la
chine c'est devenu l' usine de la
planète et on y fabrique des tas de
trucs indispensable alors imaginez que
l'épidémie coronavirus soit mam est mal
maîtrisée que les usines s'arrêtent à
nouveau ben il est à deux choses qui
vont nous manquer bon bain par exemple
la joie que vous avez un téléphone
portable
c'est vrai 70 pour s'adapter les
portables sont fabriqués en chine vous
êtes vous en passez vous me remettez non
non non ce qui nous regarde sont
concernés 50% des télés sont fabriqués
en chine
donc si les chinois ne sont pas là pour
fabriquer le triomphe et comment ce
premier à dire le journal on lit des
livres peints de pages non mais ça va ça
va être affreux myriam on a l'impression
de vous présenter un peu ce soir mais
est-ce que c'est grave vraiment grave
cette julie naud des périodes un petit
peu ce qui m'amuse c'est qu'en fait on a
l'impression aujourd'hui de découvrir
une nouvelle chose une maladie d'un seul
coup qui nous tomberait dessus la sino
dépendance alors que ça fait là même qui
date quand même de depuis 30 ans les
chiffres pour les médicaments sont
éloquents il ya dans les années 90 donc
il ya 30 ans 80% des produits actifs
dans les médicaments étaient fabriqués
en europe
aujourd'hui 80% des principes actifs des
médicaments sont fabriqués en chine et
c'est bien sûr pas pareil
pour plein d'autres produits on finira
pas d'en faire la liste cercle la chine
c'est quand même moins cher il n'y a pas
de syndicat c'est toujours avantageux
donc on a une productivité importante
alors il ya un inconvénient c'est
qu'effectivement il est aller retour en
bateau on a donc ils polluent énormément
mais au final on s'y retrouve donc cette
crise du cornet virus finalement à une
va peut-être paris prendre conscience de
quelque chose qui existe depuis très
longtemps enfin c'est ce qu'a délire
laird a dit reprenant le meilleur à ce
matin et je pense qu'il faut tirer les
conséquences de long terme de cette
situation ça fait plusieurs mois que je
dis qu'il faut que nous réfléchissions à
renforcer la souveraineté économique
l'indépendance économique d'autres pays
en ayant la capacité de produire un
certain nombre de biens qui sont
stratégiques pour notre industrie en
france ou en europe et pas uniquement en
chine
alors ça veut dire que cette crise va
nous inciter à relocaliser nos
entreprises pour ne plus dépendre de la
chine vraiment vous surprenez pas ce que
vous vous exprimez exactement de la même
manière que donald trump puisqu'il n'est
pas agréé dans votre style à priori mais
bon c'est comme ça parce que c'est qu'à
une guerre économique avec les états
unis et la chine donc cet été trump a
tweeté comme il le fait d'habitude
voilà il a donné ordre aux entreprises
américaines de quitter la chine pour
revenir s'installer aux laissa donc
bruno le maire n'a pas tout à fait le
même style trop déçu quand il tape du
poing sur la table bruno ça fait un peu
moins de bruit que donald trump mais en
même temps ils sont sur la même longueur
d'onde
on a le sentiment aujourd'hui d'un seul
coup classe i know dépendance est une
menace pour les pays occidentaux donc
quel est le remède
ben on est là pour en débattre merci
stéphane ya beaucoup de choses dans son
billet ce soir on va reprendre les
questions les unes après les autres jean
pierre raffarin déjà sur la question
envisagez de sortir de la dépendance à
la faveur finalement d'une crise
sanitaire d'une crise qui fragilise la
chine est ce que la question vous semble
légitime
on sait pas le moment après tout moi
toutes les questions sur la chine sont
légitimes c'est un sujet d'une rare
complexité c'est on avait un diplomate
qui s'appelle paul claudel qui était
diplomate en chine et donc il
connaissait très bien la chine et on lui
demandait toujours alors qu'est ce que
vous pensez des chinois votre question
embarrasse je ne les connais pas tous
la chine c'est très grand et c'est très
difficile à comprendre tellement détendu
claude est donc assez prudent dans les
analyses d'une manière parce que on
découvre aujourd'hui que la chine est la
première économie du monde
depuis 2014 en parité de pouvoir d'achat
c'est à dire que c'est pas aujourd'hui
qu'il aujourd'hui que les pianos les
raquettes de tennis deux tiers des
jouets sont fabriqués en chine et nous
sommes dépendants de la chine
mais nous sommes aussi dépendant des
états unis puisque les les devis nous
font fermer nos usines total en iran
nous fermer ps de l'aele dextérité mais
sanitaires réalisés que nos économies
évidemment sont appelés à marquer c'est
ce que je veux dire c'est que
l'interdépendance
elle est partout un sûr que la chine
dépend de nous pour son énergie
nucléaire et pour beaucoup de sujets
comme nous nous dépendons aussi de
l'inde comme nous dépendons aussi des
états égalité volets dont les rapports
de police mais bien sûr puisque par
secteur tout dépend les sujets mais nous
sommes très dépendants de l'allemagne
premier client et premier fournisseur
donc ce qu'il faut bien voir aujourd'hui
c'est que nous sommes dans un monde
interdépendant et donc c'est vrai que
nous avons des dépendance vis à vis de
la chine mais je suis assez étonné de
voir que tout le monde découvre
aujourd'hui cette situation alors qu'au
fond vous avez le real vous avez
c'est malin avait sanofi vous êtes
toutes les grandes entreprises
françaises qui font un business d'enfer
suite d'informations puisque vous avez
beaucoup de contacts en chine déjà est
ce que vous êtes inquiet pour les
entreprises françaises vous l'avais dit
dans la région du hubei dans la région
de kurram a énormément d'entreprises
français et allemand des dizaines et des
dizaines de textos français psa accord
lvmh sanofi seb et j'en passe une partie
des salariés ont été rapatriés
les usines sont à l'arrêt qu'est ce qui
se passe ça veut dire que je alors
disons pour la production
les informations qu'ils deviennent il
faut être très prudent les informations
qui viennent dit ce qu on aime on pense
qu'on vient de passer le pic
c'est à dire que a priori déjà à
l'extérieur du roubaix les usines sont
en train de repartir et je vois que dans
l'automobile par exemple y compris des
constructeurs qui nous concerne un grand
nombre de deux usines sont à nouveau au
travail
donc tout dépend de la leçon du bc thann
où là naturellement il ya encore des
usines qui sont à rennes vous êtes
inquiet vous pour toutes ces entreprises
en france qui attendent des journées
seraient je pense que il ya
naturellement un impact économique très
fort parce qu'il ya les nos produits de
marque et de tous nos produits de luxe
ça n'aurait rien vendu pendant les 15
derniers jours des magasins sans aucune
vente
donc on aura un impact mais ça pour moi
c'est pas le plus grave parce que ça le
jour où l'appli pinet me sera maîtrisée
ils vont faire un plan de relance ils
savent faire ça ils rattraperont leur
croissance la question pour moi qui est
derrière cette affaire c'est la guerre
commerciale avec les états unis et la
chine
et là je pense que l'europe est plus
risquent d'être prises en otage dans
cette guerre nous risquons d'être la
balle de ping pong qui va recevoir des
coups de raquette des états unis d'un
côté de la chine de l'autre et c'est ça
notre problème c'est le réveil de
l'europe dans cette guerre commerciale
qui sera le grand sujet de 2000 band and
sur les entreprises françaises alors il
ya celles qui sont en chine il ya celle
aussi qui attendent ou qui ont des
stocks
ça dépend des pièces détachées pour
produits
est ce que vous vous êtes inquiet ya un
ralentissement de fait en effet
aujourd'hui donc la consommation en
chine est quasiment arrêtée en tout cas
sauf pour les besoins premiers à
l'alimentation et cetera mais pour tout
ce qui est production je dirais
industriel ça commence à reprendre mais
c'est comme très très au ralenti en
france nous avons en effet des usines
qui attendent des pièces et qui sont au
chômage technique aujourd'hui parce
qu'il manque de pièces pour pouvoir
produire samash technique ça veut dire
peut-être qu'on met la clé sous la porte
ou on attend et ça reprend le
gouvernement a privé les facilités à 10
heures on peut pas les charges on
retardera autres otages technique sera
autorisée facilité mais cette dépendance
a comme disait jean pierre raffarin
nous l'avons déjà depuis très longtemps
et par exemple aujourd'hui tous les
produits quasiment que nous utilisons
qui intègre des puces électroniques
beaucoup viennent des états unis on nous
avons d'autres d'autres freins d'autres
contraintes très direct nos
investissements en iran par exemple ont
été stoppés net
on les a perdu quasiment pas ce que les
américains ont décidé que on ne pouvait
plus commercer avec eux donc c'est
interdit pendant 7 ans mini je pense que
ce qui se passe aujourd'hui avec cette
crise sanitaire
les chinois vont pouvoir le rattraper
derrière en revanche la dépendance nous
avons vis-à-vis du dollar par exemple je
pense que ça fait quelques décennies il
faut absolument nous commencions à en
sortir parce qu'il n'est pas normal que
notre pays puisse décider de ce que nous
devons faire d'autres pays tiers si nous
conversons pas dans aucun pays comme
l'iran ben c'est avec seulement l'accord
des états unis la vrai problème qui sont
qui sont les entreprises qui souffrent
le plus les autres peut-être juste avant
d'entrer sous l'angle économique la
priorité c'est quand même la santé des
personnes est la santé des individus nos
concitoyens de nos salariés et donc au
medef on est en contact permanent avec
les autorités de notre pays pour
connaître les bonnes pratiques et
j'invite tous les chefs d'entreprise les
entreprises à contacter leurs medef
territoriaux pour savoir qu'est ce
qu'ils doivent faire en cas d'inquiétude
d'interrogation sur des salariés et ça
c'est la priorité
si ensuite on doit parler
dès que gagnant d'économies mais avant
même de l'approvisionnement de la place
de la chine la chine et du coup
d'ailleurs de cette crise dont personne
ne connaît le coup aujourd'hui le sera
selon les statistiques des 40 milliards
et les instituts de conjoncture selon
c'était 40 milliards de vues 1 3 le
strass
peut-être que ça sera plus probablement
plus cette crise mais ce qui a
fondamentalement changé depuis le strass
c'est que la chine représentait 5% du
pib mondial
aujourd'hui ces 19 quasiment 20% la
chine représentait 5% de la croissance
mondiale aujourd'hui elle représente 30%
de la croissance mondiale monsieur le
premier ministre évoquait les marques de
luxe les marques de luxe vendre 35 % de
leur produit en chine
alors effectivement il ya un
ralentissement bien que bien que les
informations qu'on a c'est qu'ils
continuent à avoir des ventes en ligne
mais c'est un mmo c'est un exemple par
contre là on a un problème plus global
c'est un vrai sujet de souveraineté de
souveraineté monsieur le premier
ministre monsieur le député le rappelait
je vais vous dire il n'y a pas une
société européenne dans le top 50 tech
mondiale vous l'avez rappelé sur les
principes actifs pour les médicaments
sur les chaînes de valeur et vous disiez
on n'a pas le choix
mais bien sûr qu'on a le choix c'est des
choix fiscaux qu'on a fait aussi dans
notre pays depuis vingt ou trente ans la
désindustrialisation n'est pas venu par
hasard vous avez ce qu'on appelle dans
notre pays des impôts de production
c'est des impôts sur le produire en
france
vous savez quoi ces impôts ils ont
explosé ils sont passés en dix ans de 50
à 75 milliards ar on va dire le medef il
est toujours idéologues il veut toujours
payer moins d'impôts mais non on n'est
pas des obsédés de l'impôt mais ça a des
conséquences directes réel pour nos
jeunes et nos villes trump lui par
exemple une guerre commerciale sur les
tarifs douaniers est ce que vous auriez
pas leur nom défend alors là c'est rare
que le medef des français économique
on défend cette taxe carbone aux
frontières européennes parce qu'on peut
pas continuer comme ça imposer à nos
entreprises des règlements très la
mettre en oeuvre et pour l'instant il
avec le président le président de la
nascar dont ses compères est pas le
produit aux politiques au niveau des
patronats et c'est très important
président geoffroy roux de bézieux est
allé à rome il ya un accord avec la
copine d'austria et le bdia c'est pas
rien c'est important on n'est pas trop
déçu par les mois des petites
entreprises un instant puis je vous
donne la parole juste après
on a du stock pour je pense à des
petites pme qui n'ont pas forcément
énormément
voilà deux de visibilité sur l'avenir
est-ce qu'il ya voir en gros de la casse
sociale à la faveur de cette crise
écoutez france n'a de boule de cristal
aujourd'hui on essaye d'agréger les
choses bien sûr qu'il ya des difficultés
pas forcément pour des paiements pour
des grands groupes aussi vous parliez du
secteur automobile et oui mais le
secteur automobile etr avec des
sous-traitants et de temps en temps
c'est sous traitance et des entreprises
de taille intermédiaire et ça peut même
mettre des pme et donc quand il n'y a
pas de production et qui à du chômage
partiel et le sous-traitant il a pas de
carnet de commandes en fait on pense que
la formation mais il ya un choc d'afro
circuit à moins de produits je vous
rappelle juste qu'il ya eu des blocages
de porc en france on n'en a peut-être
pas beaucoup parlé mais qui ont aussi
des structures et les filières
d'approvisionnement récemment je pense
au havre je pense à la rochelle et à
d'autres portent donc il faut faire
attention aussi à ses infrastructures
on a tous des fonctionnaires qui
deviennent de produits chinois ne sont
pas arrivés ils sont à l'arrêt je
voudrais qu'on fasse un arrêt sur les
médicaments et on passe à la question au
fond est-ce qu'on doit en sortir
et si oui comment est ce que c'est
possible mais les médicaments c'est
édifiant comme exemple héloïse grégoire
et a rencontré bruno bonnes mains de
l'académie nationale de pharmacie pour
bien prendre la mesure de la dépendance
au fond de notre dépendance à la chine
en matière de médicaments
les dépendants pour deux raisons aient
eu d'abord une raison économique parce
que l'arrivée des génériques a fait que
les prix ont fortement baissé donc il a
fallu trouver des pays où la production
était moins cher donc on s'est tourné
vers l'asie la chine et l'inde en
particulier mais il ya une deuxième
raison qui est au moins aussi importante
que la raison environnementale
parce qu'un certain nombre de produits
sont polluants et donc on a envoyé en
chine et en inde est produit dans la
production posait un problème en europe
pour ce qui concerne la matière première
80% et produits en asie soit en inde
sont chine en chine est à peu près 3000
usine en inde 4 piles donc ça veut dire
que très peu de matières premières sont
produits en europe
s'il ya une crise sanitaire ou une crise
environnementale ou même une crise
politique à la limite on est
complètement dépendante de la chine et
de l'inde y a plus un gramme de penser
tellement qu'ils produiront
il ya plus un gramme de paracétamol qui
est produit en europe ça fait ça fait
réfléchir lucie schmidt il ya un débat
qui commence à émerger sur faut-il
relocaliser les chaînes de production
faut-il repenser nos systèmes de
production
qu'est ce que vous en pensez je pense
que ce qui est assez passionnant c'est
que c'est un débat qui préexistait à la
crise du coronavirus c'est à dire que
j'allais dire on voit tout tous seuls
nous montebourg en marinière quand on
pense à ça et donc ça fait déjà quelques
années que ça existe qui a aussi des
études économiques très intéressantes
comme celle de mme houde hellmund qui a
un professeur à dauphine qui a très bien
expliqué comment la relocalisation et
est aujourd'hui un phénomène extrêmement
marginale mais qu'en revanche on
hésitait beaucoup plus à délocaliser
qu'avant c'est à dire qu'il ya un sujet
sur décidé de délocaliser relocaliser
c'est plus compliqué mais au fond on
continue à produire en france alors que
la chine est en train de changer comme
le disait jean pierre raffarin
la chine c'est un bon autant de chinois
autant de chine quelque part c'est ce
que vous disiez mais en tout cas les
salaires augmentent
il est clair que la chine veut se
développer autrement que notamment elle
porte des plans environnementaux très
intéressant et que elle elle mène pour
l'instant elle a des mondes parallèles
la chine c'est à dire qu'à la fois
effectivement on y produit des choses en
chimie qu'on ne produiraient jamais en
europe et en même temps on y met en
place des plans climat comme n'en
produirait jamais en europe c'est un
truc assez extraordinaire alors il ya
des gens qui attribue sa ou à l'intérêt
du régime autoritaire on peut aussi là
la tribu et peut-être au génie chinois
parfois enfin bon en tout cas il ya
quelque chose qui se passe en chine qui
nous oblige à réfléchir à nous mais moi
ce que je trouve très passionnant dans
cette crise du coronavirus c'est que ça
dévoile notre dépendance mais dont nous
sommes responsables
au fond c'est ce que disent vos
reportages sais ce que c'est que nous
disons autour de la table aujourd'hui la
plupart enfin une très grande majorité
des exportations chinoises sont
produites avec des entreprises
étrangères en joint-venture
il ya aussi des entreprises chinoises
mais en tout cas autour de 50% au moins
de ski et exportés de chine
ça dépend de nous donc c'est un choix
que nous avons fait en considérant que
la chine était notre usine est par
exemple lorsque nous nous targuons de
produire moins de co2 c'est parce que au
fond nous allons produire notre co2 en
chine où que nous allons produire notre
chimique polluante enchaîné une ferme
des banques n'est ni forme d'hypocrisie
et de responsabilité que nous devons
reprendre en discutant bien sûr avec les
chinois est aussi pardon pour ne pas
être trop longue mais en portant aussi
au niveau européen un projet qui soit
plus clair sur sur ces enjeux c'est à
dire à la fois très fort vis-à-vis des
etats-unis porter un vrai projet
environnemental et exister comme
puissance internationale lorsqu'il
s'agit de diplomatie est ce que c'est
possible réellement de sortir de cette
dépendance
personnellement je pense que c'est n'est
possible qu'au niveau européen
je pense qu'il faut pas faire croire aux
français qu'on va être le rapport de
force avec les états unis à côté avec la
chine de l'eau cette la logique
européenne qui peut peut-être nous aider
vous parlez de l'aspirine par
incidemment on a été trop naïf a dit
récemment il ya quelques mois vis-à-vis
de la chine le président français
le président on a cru au fond que ans
commerçant avec la chine
il y aura une démocratie peut-être à
terme qui allaient émerger et et que
dans l'eau que les rapports commerciaux
serait plus équitable ces deux sujets
différents ça ces deux sujets différents
et puis je devrais plus l'incident a
bloqué dans ses montées mais il ya
beaucoup de gens qui le disaient
l'occident s'est complètement trompé
pensant que l'inde la chine ouvrant ces
marchés que le marché allait amener la
démocratie et on a parié et les états
unis ont parié sur une évolution
démocratique de la chine est en fait si
jenny pic le dis clairement le pouvoir
il est le socialisme à caractéristiques
chinoises
qu'est ce que la caractérise chinois
c'est le leadership du parti c'est la
loi du parti qui s'applique
donc il est clair à n'a pas marché ça
n'a pas marché non plus dans une forme
d'équilibré des forces ça n'a pas marché
ça n'a pas marché pour les chinois pour
l'économie ils sont quand même devenu en
32 ans
la première économie du monde donc là je
vous rejoins sur la dimension humaine
parce que dans ceux des discussions il
faut aussi penser aujourd'hui au peuple
chinois
on peut être en désaccord avec jean ping
an peut être que contre le régime
communiste je suis évidemment mais il
faut quand même penser aujourd'hui avec
un peu de compassion à ce qu'ils aient
preuve que la question de se poser ils
font la dépendance chinoise à la faveur
d'une crise sanitaire
elle se pose lorsqu'on n'est pas trop
égoïste andino ça non il est temps de
sortir est énorme et je pense que l'on
peut essayer de faire en sorte que notre
stratégie industrielle redémarrent mais
ne faisons pas croire que on découvre
les choses maintenant le problème
aujourd'hui
quand monsieur macron reçoit monsieur
jean ping
il reçoit avec madame merkel avec
monsieur juncker c'est à dire qui dit
clairement à ce moment là nos réponses
sont européennes et donc la question
aujourd'hui c'est le réveil de l'europe
l'europe va sortir de l'histoire si elle
n'est pas capable de construire une
relation équilibrée
à nous de la chine et les états unis
donc là la question aujourd'hui c'est
pas de se dire et de faire de la pub va
essayer de reconstruire notre industrie
séoul a globalement c est ce que
l'europe est capable d'être le troisième
pôle dans ce système bipolaire qui
s'annonce et qui va nous sortir de
l'histoire
la chine c'est vraiment un mauvais sujet
ils font ce qu'ils peuvent pour se
développer ils ont une offre d'ailleurs
les délocalisations sont pas forcément
pour aller produire dans la vision usine
du monde il ya des délocalisations qui
sont simplement pour se rapprocher des
marchés
ce que la chine est aussi un marché de
consommation l'asie du sud est est un
marché de consommation donc on a des
entreprises françaises qui vont là bas
que pâques seulement pour rechercher des
coûts moindres
mais pour se rapprocher de consommateurs
par ailleurs chez automobiles comme le
marché automobile
par ailleurs le lien de dépendance
vis-à-vis des etats-unis ils posent
autant question que vis-à-vis de la
chine
quand les services de renseignement
français utilisent une solution
américaine pour pour traiter les flux de
données massifs ballan tir pour pas le
citer ça pose question
alors est ce que c'est un choix qu'ils
ont faits volontairement maintenance et
à défaut de solution française bien
évidemment
deux solutions européennes parce que
tout se passe à l'échelle du bon sens
mais si ce mythe
moi ce que je voulais dire c'est que
puisque je suis là pour parler
d'écologie qu'il ya d'important c'est
qu'effectivement cette question des
transports on sait que les transports
c'est le principal secteurs polluants en
termes d'empreinte écologique et
notamment à l'échelle mondiale c'est le
premier en france est le deuxième mais
en tout cas ça c'est très important et
la question aujourd'hui des
délocalisations et des relocalisations
je pense que l'engouement justifié et
pour la question écologique les
dynamiques sociales démocratiques qui
existent vont sans doute obliger à des
décisions économiques différentes
on le sait parce qu'en terme d'image des
entreprises ça joue un rôle fondamental
ça a été rappelé tout à l'heure par
stéphane votre chroniqueur qui au fond
nous disait il ya les entreprises mais
aussi le consommateur c'est à dire que
tout se joue entre l'entreprise le
consommateur l'image qu'elle peut avoir
les produits qui sont offerts et là la
question écologique n'est plus une
question simplement de discours ou de
greenwashing
elle est là pour faire évoluer les
produits et quelque part
aujourd'hui l'entrepreneur réfléchi
différemment que ce soit d'ailleurs en
chine en france en europe et c est pour
rebondir sur la question européenne qui
me semble être un point essentiel pour
associer écologie et europe on voit bien
que recelait von der leyen qu'est ce
qu'elle fait aujourd'hui comme grands
projets elle fait le green new deal
d'ailleurs il ya une interrogation très
intéressant mais pas fait encore un oui
enfin élevé en cours elle s'est lancée
elle use une expression qui au fond lui
permet d'être approuvé par le parlement
européen parce que sinon c'est est
extraordinairement difficile et c'est la
première fois qu'on voit au fond une
présidente de la commission européenne
ozil se lancer dans une forme de
créativité sur le projet européen depuis
longtemps et c'est intéressant que
s'attache à vous poser sur wii je vous
est notre meilleure alliée
internationale sur ce sujet parmi les
grandes puissances
parce que cela voudrait dire c'est la
chine est ce que c'est les états unis
est ce que oui douce où on trouve des
alliés sur ce sujet du développement
j'hésiterais entre la chine et l'inde
parce que je pense que l'un des tués est
en termes technologiques en termes de
culture
c'est énorme et je pense que c'est un
pays plus démocratique je pense
qu'aujourd'hui la chine doit se tirer de
ce qui s'est passé à hong kong et tout à
l'heure c'était évoqué et moi je veux
bien qu'on compare les états unis
et la chine mais je pense que ce qui
s'est passé en kong était extrêmement
préoccupant est que là dessus il faut
qu'ils évoluent très vite de dépendance
économique j'ai pas compris enfin oui
mais c'était un bar poêlé la fabrication
du de l'économique de la politique et du
démocratique est forte et donc moi
j'hésiterais entre entre l'inde et la
chine
donc c'est l'asie et ses jeux c'est
aujourd'hui qu'est là c'est l'asie je
vais inquiet d'un nos partenaires en ce
qui concerne les grands défis du
changement sur les écrans la vision
saint pierre sur les étages on partage
depuis des années mais sûr mais faisons
attention à voir ce que les sociétés
proposent pas ce qu'il ya un sujet
étatique
il ya un sujet de société sur l'écologie
qui bonsoir essarts bonsoir servait
relie qui viennent ne rejoint notre
chroniqueur richard qui est le
correspondant parisien pour le quotidien
suisse le temps et qui vient dans cette
émission nous apporter son regard dans
ce débat alors que faire avec la chine
en fait on se demande aussi du côté des
investissements on sait que beaucoup
d'investissements chinois en europe on
pense au port du pirée
bien évidemment l'aéroport de toulouse
1-1 moment l'italie également notamment
sur ces fameuses routes de la soie ce
qu'on a eu raison de leur faire
confiance
alors effectivement y myriam on parle
beaucoup d'interdépendance mais il y a
un énorme projet qui est à l'oeuvre
depuis déjà plusieurs années c'est le
projet des routes de la soie que défend
le président xi jinping et ce projet
consiste à au fond construire des
infrastructures sur plusieurs continents
on a beaucoup parlé de l'afrique mais
également en europe et on a vu qu au
moment de la crise financière un pays
comme la grèce mais aussi l'italie ont
accepté de confier à la chine un certain
nombre de projets déterminant pour la
grèce vous l'avez dit c'est le port du
pirée
alors la question du coronavirus elle se
pose quand même sur ces routes de la
soie qui sont rappelons le des routes
millénaire jean pierre raffarin le sait
fort bien il est un livre qui a été
écrit sur le sujet de l'historien
britannique peter francophone ce sont
des routes qui ont toujours charrier des
pèlerins des écrivains des scientifiques
à travers l'asie centrale et qui relié à
l'époque lempire de milieux et l'europe
de la renaissance
alors la question aujourd'hui c'est
quand même monsieur raffarin peut-on
faire confiance à la chine lorsqu'on lui
confie
lorsqu'on lui donne de telles
infrastructures lorsqu'on lui donne la
gestion d'un port la gestion de flux de
containers il y as au delà de la simple
question de là
la dépendance commerciale il y à une
question de transparence il y à une
question d' échange d'informations on
voit bien quand même qu'aujourd'hui le
parti communiste chinois
on ne sait pas trop s'il n'a pas fait de
la rétention d'informations sur ce virus
on ne sait pas encore ce qui a été caché
ce qui a été divulgué
alors quand on a les routes de la soie
quand on est interconnecté ce qui est
votre désir est votre projet aussi juste
un constat
absolument et bien il faut qu'il y ait
des panneaux de signalisation sur ces
routes de la soie et le grand enjeu en
réalité pour l'europe ce n'est pas
seulement de penser à relocaliser ces
industries c'est aussi de réfléchir à
comment rendre ces infrastructures
davantage fiable comment faire en sorte
que la chine ne soit pas seulement un
partenaire mais surtout à partenaires
avec lesquels on peut se dire les choses
on peut comprendre les mêmes choses et
être informé en temps réel
parce que la soie oui mais le virus non
st pierre raffarin une réaction je suis
assez d'accord sur le tout les
scepticismes qu'on peut avoir sur les
informations dans les régimes qui ne
sont pas transparents qui n'ont pas le
pluralisme de la presse qui n'ont pas la
pratique du débat comme tendon
démocratie donc ça sur ces sujets là je
vais pas dire que je défends le système
politique de la chine
je suis un démocrate attaché à la
démocratie
ce que je veux simplement dire c'est que
faisons attention non plus à ne pas
donner des leçons parce que nous n'avons
pas été toujours très transparent sur
tous les grands sujets et qui donc
faisons très attention parce que ce qui
arrive avec ce virus de mon point de vue
ça peut arriver à n'importe quel pays ça
peut nous arriver en afrique
ça nous est arrivé d'ailleurs avec ebola
on a un certain nombre qui militent
chaussures sur les quais rapport we are
on peut envoyer les désigner on peut
désigner tel ou tel moment mais soyons
vraiment très prudent d'abord un comme
vous le disiez très justement la
compassion d'abord avec le peuple
quelle que soit la position qu'on a sur
le régime et puis deuxièmement soyons
assez prudents parce que ce qui peut
arriver aujourd'hui dans toutes ces
difficultés sanitaires ça peut arriver
partout on a vu la vache folle on a eu
un certain nombre de sujets sur lesquels
la transparence n'était pas forcément
idéal ce que je veux dire en terminant
sur ce point c'est que ce qui est clair
aujourd'hui c'est que on voit bien dans
le débat politique
finalement très souvent les populismes
divers et variés appelle la frontière
comme solution mais est-ce que la
frontière règle la question du climat
est ce que la frontière règle la
question du virus je ne le crois pas et
ce que je vois aujourd'hui c'est que
c'est la coopération qui peut régler les
preuves ou ne faites pas partie des
critiques la gestion de la crise
sanitaire en france
je peux quand même avoir eu la tentation
de cacher des choses au dec dépit des
mesures sur ce sujet là je pense que il
ya sans doute eu des retards néanmoins
moi j'ai vécu j'étais en chine en 2003
pendant la sphère du strass l'a10 les
décisions ont mis des mois aujourd'hui
elles ont mis des semaines en trois
semaines ils ont engagé un plan de
mobilisation exceptionnelle et tous les
scientifiques français reconnaissent qu'
il y a eu une forte mobilisation
trois semaines peut-être sans doute mais
avant de donner des leçons faut être sûr
que nous on est capable de faire aussi
bien dans bien des domaines
brenntag vous aurez eu le mot de la fin
vous dire agir et puis j'aurai cette
question au foie ce que les démocraties
que nous sommes sont peut-être plus
compétents plusieurs mm ou moins à même
de gérer ces crises sanitaires par
contre tout d'abord d'abord je voudrais
souligner le fait que aujourd'hui au
bourg ain qui est l'épicentre de cette
épidémie
le seul consulat de conçu le consul
général aujourd'hui en place encore
aujourd'hui c'est le français trop sujet
les français vont franchement la seule
journaliste au monde je me permets
d'ajouter ça qui est dans la ville de
maurane est tout à fait donc voilà là
dessus déjà et puis pour le peuple
chinois
ça fait des semaines que nous
travaillons à envoyer du matériel ça
peut aider et je pense que c'est assez
en ce moment qu'il faut montrer cette
compassion et pas te parler
ensuite j'étais avec ma jambe usa hier
et on a parlé encore de cette épidémie
et abusé a dit clairement à des
décisions qui ont été prises par le
peuple chinois et par le gouvernement
chinois ont été très gros a surtout été
les seuls aujourd'hui les bonnes les
seuls qu'il fallait prendre parce que ça
permet de confiner de ralentir le
développement surtout à l'étranger tant
pas pourquoi mais chic que pour les
chinois et pour tous les pays où
alentours y compris la france
je pense que c'était vraiment important
et je ne pense vraiment pas
qu'aujourd'hui genou volonté de cacher
il est autoritaire ou démocratie même
combat contre le dire je dirais même que
ça je pense qu'il est très difficile
pour nous en france par exemple de
prendre une décision de confier des
dizaines de millions de personnes c'est
juste je pense
impossible à faire merci on va s'arrêter
là merci à vous d'être venu sur le
plateau de lcp vous restez avec nous un
jour pierre raffarin parce qu'on va
parler à présent de vous nous sommes
allés demander aux députés
moi je veux vous dire avez vous laissé à
l'assemblée quel adjectif leur venait à
l'esprit pour vous caractérisez regardez
ce que ça donne été compilés par maïté
frémaux ce que je pense de monsieur
raffarin jean pierre raffarin est un
sage ce n'est pas vraiment ma tasse de
thé mais il a accompagné le président
chirac dans ses années de gloire
gouvernement de jean pierre raffarin
doit maintenant concrétiser les
promesses de campagne une image que j'ai
de lui c'est un échange à l'assemblée à
l'assemblée nationale entre marie george
buffet est lui-même à l'occasion d'une
motion de censure suite je crois un 49 3
me semble-t-il l'honneur monsieur le
président de vous faire connaître qu'en
application de l'article 49 alinéa 3 de
la constitution j'ai décidé après
délibération du conseil des ministres
qui m'y a autorisé d'engager la
responsabilité du gouvernement
vous avez qualifié l'exercice du droit
constitutionnel d'amendements de
désordre quel mépris pour le parlement
c'est ma première expérience politique
jean ferrat parfaite et 2005
j'organise les manifestations lycéennes
à calais mois contre la réforme fillon
qui s'occupait de l'éducation
nationale il est c'était jean-pierre à
part le premier ministre
il avait des jeux de mots extraordinaire
des rats farina de moi me faisait
beaucoup rire dans cette situation notre
route est droite mais la pente est forte
pour moi monsieur raffarin il incarne
nos relations avec la chine
et je crois qu'il a été l'un des
premiers à comprendre l'importance de
des relations entre nos deux pays
je sais que dans ma propre famille
politique il n'a plus aujourd'hui que
des amis là aussi quelques-uns qui
regrette son départ
mais jean pierre raffarin fait partie de
ceux dont la parole et est recherché
écoute et qui apporte je crois très
sincèrement un autre regard à notre vie
politique et moi je lui en suis toujours
grave
et voilà pour cet échantillon de
réaction on va vous demander ce que vous
en pensez dans un instant mais j'en
profite pour saluer nos invités nico
nature quoi bienvenus vous êtes le
rapporteur pour la majorité de cette
fameuse réforme des retraites cette
course de lenteur dans l'hémicycle
françois durpaire bienvenus d'ordinaire
vous nous parler des élections
américaines mais vous allez nous parler
du filibuster inc on attend et on a hâte
de savoir de quoi il s'agit et âmes d'un
gamin
merci d'être là vous suffisait ce
dossier des retraites pour lcp la chine
les raffarinade et jacques chirac
ça vous va comme triptyque écoutez si
vous y ajoutez le poitou et le
futuroscope et quelques autres petites
choses opérationnelle territoriale ça va
très bien vous avez jusque vous mentez à
certains députés la république et a
manifestement il me manque aussi
pas de regret d'avoir quitté la famille
ont finalement je suis parti à 69 ans je
m'étais dit que je ne serai plus
parlementaires à 70 ans donc j'ai
démissionné de mon mandat quand je suis
arrivé à cet âge là j'avais décidé ça
depuis longtemps et je trouve que c'est
très bien de prendre un peu de liberté
de distance et puis de laisser la place
des gens manquent pression de grandes
figures votre formation politique
aujourd'hui
enfin votre formation votre ancienne
formation écoutez c'est difficile de
dire si c'est un un signe de
vieillissement quand on commence à
nouveau là le
niveau actuel est un peu faible c'était
meilleur avant donc je me méfie de ces
approches là je vois qu'il ya des grands
talents il ya aussi des défilés on a du
mal à situer politiquement aujourd'hui
vous avez soutenu
emmanuel macron jusqu'aux européennes
vous étiez pour cette cette liste en
marche aux municipales à paris par
exemple les crimes non non moi je vote
thomas dans la commune au vote ce qui
s'appelle châtelaillon je vais voter
pour la liste de sens car je suis je
suis avec le centre droit je rêvais mais
ici pas la même que la droite reprend un
peu ses biz chez claire's ou les moules
les européennes il est clair que je
pense que c'est le président la
république qui conduit la politique
européenne de la france et qu'il faut
pas le fragiliser
donc je trouve qu'il ya des choses très
utile que je fais emmanuel macron je
crois que c'est pas la peine de chercher
à le déstabiliser
systématiquement qu'on était d'accord
mais écoutez je suis un audacieux que je
ne suis pas gelé le monde je les aime
toutes les deux je suis pas parisien est
d'ailleurs très franchement vous savez
c'est très difficile de comprendre la
politique à paris il faut se méfier des
soins c'est arrondissement par
arrondissement
ça va aller à la fin au conseil
municipal je ne sais pas quels sont les
alliances
donc soyons très prudent mais non je
connais bien rachida dati je la connais
bien à la vrai talent elle a de l'audace
à la désinformation
elle et elle est très active mahdia mme
buzyn je la connais moins mais j'ai
apprécié c'est un peu son action au
gouvernement donc ce sont des des femmes
estimable que la meilleure gagne
bon alors on ne saura pas qui est et
sera votre choix pour pour les
présidentielles simplement vous rester
comme ça aussi en retrait vous l'aviez
dans la vème république est trop tôt le
président est nommé en charge de
l'essentiel donc c'est un peu un
référendum pour ou contre le président
donc de deux choses l'une où le
président macron sera en situation de
dominer la vie politique parce qu'il
sera le sortant et là je ne vois pas
pourquoi il faudrait l'empêcher si le
président macron se trouve dans une
impasse ide à ce moment là nous verrons
qui peut apparaître et donc à droite
apparaissent des gens aujourd'hui il ya
des gens qui font un travail françois
baroin par exemple et quelques autres
nous verrons le moment venu mais
n'oublions pas la vème république
la cinquième d'un public tout est
articulé autour du président fragilisé
le président ne pas fragiliser le
président s'est dit j'ai entendu dire
que vous souhaitiez une réforme
institutionnelle mais restait dans la
vème république
4 euros pour les députés au lieu de cinq
de façon à quoi recréer la cohabitation
nonce les de façon à éviter que le
président de la république soit au coeur
de toutes les protestations la vème
république était fait pour que le
président essaie tant est que tous les
cinq ans il y avait une élection
législative et donc les législatives été
l'occasion d'un grand débat national
aujourd'hui on vote pour un président
l'assemblée arrive juste derrière le
président et pendant cinq ans le système
a fait mieux que personne
pourtant jacques c'était jacques chirac
valéry giscard d'estaing lionel jospin
c'était à une action très consensuel
quand je pense qu'il faut découpler les
législatives et l'élection
présidentielle il ya deux choses qui me
paraissent très importante un des
couples est est saturée des prix ancien
et de relancer la décentralisation qui
est un projet qui est à l'étude en ce
moment j'étais plancher totalement vous
et voilà je pense que là il ya des
choses que tu avais il faut avancer il
faut décongestionner l'état parce qu'ils
m'ont puisque la mort cérébrale si on
laisse cette congestion cérébrale
s'installer donc il faut ouvrir les tec
toi pourquoi le président de la
république serait t'il en charge de tous
les sons respirer des territoires il ya
des politiques qui peuvent très bien
décentraliser les sons le président
comme le disait de gaulle sur
l'essentiel
non il faut qu'il soit sur l'essentiel
régalien lefort pleurer gagnant puis
d'un certain terre de grands sujets
comme l'éducatif qui sont des des sujets
très importants de cohérence nationale
mais il faut que le président de la
république ne soit pas en charge de tout
et du reste c'est dit on pas sa retraite
si vous ne voulez bien
rien ne va plus dans l'hémicycle je vous
le disais les esprits s'échauffent et
les nerfs lâchent les vôtres notamment
nicolas turquois manifestement vous
n'avez pas vraiment leur 9e
digérer vous allez nous le dire les
milliers d'amendements de la france
insoumise et des communistes on regarde
ce que ça donnait hier soir était tard
il faut le dire dans l'hémicycle
certains parmi vous ont déclaré la
république c'est moi
et bien moi je vous dis que la
république si nous et vous vous êtes
arrière
monsieur le ministre vous avez une vraie
opposition elle est légitime votre
position elle est légitime mais ce mode
de fonctionnement
à chaque fois vous vous exprimez vos
arguments à chaque fois on y revient une
série de 600 amendements je suis désolé
on fait pas grandir collectivement le
parlement ça ne rime à rien c'est ce que
je voulais exprimer alors je suis désolé
de ma tournure tt sur le le coup de deux
de l'envolée mais je vous un cirque on
se grandirait alors on le sait depuis
vous vous êtes un peu aux excuses et
clairement ce sont ce sont des excuses
plate que vous avez faite à l'opposition
vous avez un peu insulté en disant
qu'elle était rien mais tombe où je vous
écris franchement on a eu une série de
600 amendements qui dès qu'elle est
l'entrée en vigueur du système de
retraites
année après année est donc un rapporteur
de la loi et c'est pas monsieur le
premier ministre que je l'expliqué il
doit travailler sur le fond pour pouvoir
expliquer les notamment les éléments les
plus techniques pourquoi les choix ont
été faits dans ce sens là donc qui je
dois travailler sur le fond pour
apporter des réponses de fond l'accord
vous avez 600 amendements qui décale
d'un an un an un an un an et où on
arrivait à la route la mise en place de
ce système en 2082 c'est à dire que pour
les enfants menée en 2082 dont leurs
parents ne sont même pas nés il ya un
côté 600 un moment vous attendez ça
pendant une heure et demie des
argumentaires et à un moment ça là on
est donc j'ai répondu d'abord à
l'absurde par l'absurde en sortant le
choix de 1975 pourquoi est-ce qu'on ait
choisi mieux son tour c'était j'ai fait
un certain nombre de répondants de bons
mots et puis et puis oui à un moment
donné sûrement le côté humain il h on
est on essaye de répondre avec attention
et puis avec avec concision et avec le
plus de renseignements possibles
et puis en face il ya une opposition qui
n'est pas là pour travailler sur le fond
mais qui est là pour bloquer le système
et je trouve que j'avais l'impression
hier soir va partenaires au cirque de
guignol au théâtre de guignol et d'en
être un des acteurs et d'en être un des
acteurs de
le fait de fait ça vous rappelle des
souvenirs j'ai une d'oiseaux qui fusent
comme ça vous en pensez quoi
bon faut que ça s'arrête on vous faut
une ligne rouge est franchie
d'expression et quand on travaille comme
ça avec 48 la bombe ont d'abord faut pas
faire un drame sur tout ça moi j'ai
connu plus de cent mille abonnements il
ya des textes à 140 mille amendements
donc l'option de l'obstruction c'est pas
d'aujourd'hui
j'ai vu la droite faire de l'obstruction
moi j'ai tenu une fois quatre heures et
demie à la tribune du sénat ba bon parce
qu'il fallait gagner du temps parce que
et puis la gauche faisait la même chose
c'est toujours le même surtout au mois
de mars quand il ya des élections
le pouvoir veut toujours voter le texte
avant les élections et l'opposition veut
toujours empêché le pouvoir d'avoir ce
bénéfice électoral avant les autres le
nouveau monde cette course là elle est
vieille comme le monde donc qu'on ne se
fasse pas au fond il faut revenir à des
choses toutes simples qu'est ce que
c'est que ce 49 3 c'est le droit c'est
la constitution votée par les français
qu'est ce que la violence c'est
d'attaquer le droit comment on lutte
contre la violence en respectant le
droit le droit je crois que vous avez
connu le caroff la démocratie mais bien
bien sûr c'est la constitution c'est le
droit qu'est ce que la paix sociale
c'est le droit le respect du droit un
droit qui a été défoncé le comprendre on
s'éloigne et que les blés les foncières
vous croyez que les français ils
apprécient de voir leurs parlementaires
jour et nuit discuter sur des virgules
aurait déjà mais ça fait une semaine si
on prend je pense les 8,6 avec lancement
quand vous voyez quand vous voyez des
logique d'obstruction
les français disent et sable
l'efficacité politique ou escalettes
nous on a des problèmes concrets et on
voit un parlement qui passe son temps à
discuter sur des micro à mon arrestation
dans la rue il ya un mouvement social
l'opposition s'en fait le relais sur
elle n'est pas présente ce soir donc je
m'en fais un peu l'avocat
c'est très bien mais je ne vois pas
d'inconvénient à ce que l'opposition
s'exprime il ya plein de tribune pour
cela vous le dites vous même c'est le
jeu donc y'a
je crois sur ce terrain si l'idée de
principe ccc le droit en 5ème république
l'opposition a très peu de temps pour
des trajets mais ce qu'elle n'est pas au
fond dans son rôle a cherché est une
bête mais au fond elle a mille façons de
s'exprimer elle sait le faire mais
l'obstruction parlementaire par de la
procédure
c'est pas forcément ce qu'il y a de plus
créatif quand on a des idées quand on a
des mobilisations et s'ils font
toussaint c'est aussi plein parce qu'il
ne se consacre pas ceux de l'opposition
en tout cas les plus actifs se consacre
pas la préparation des municipales
on est dans une situation politique
aujourd'hui et la préparation des
municipales
qu'on laisse ces électeurs choisir que
le parlement travaille et travaille dans
le calme donc il n'y a pas de drame dans
à ce qu'il y ait à un moment ou un autre
à 49,3 quelle opposition elle fera une
motion de censure est elle votre
association
on voit le résultat avec elsa monde à
gaza où on en est si ça avance ou pas
mesdames vous vous l'attendez ce 49,3
aux foudres vous dites au gouvernement
mais laissez-nous débattre on est prêts
on vous sent d'ailleurs énergique dans
l'hémicycle donc qu'est ce que vous
attendez vous le carolo marquantes
canton bien rapporteur et qu'on
travaille sur lui puis on a envie de les
porter puisque j'en suis j'ai
théoriquement 22 articles à défendre
j'en suis qu'au deuxième on vient de le
voter juste avant de venir ce serait un
soulagement pour vous ce serait
frustrant car pour l'instant ça serait
frustrant je ne sais pas où ça va
continuer pour l'instant ça serait
frustrant parce que il ya des éléments
techniques et on va dire que là on était
sur des principes généraux et à leur
type le 1 et le 2 quelles personnes vont
rentrer dedans c'est à dire tout le
monde toutes les professions voilà
maintenant on va rentrer sur les
éléments techniques et gégé et j'ai
envie sur ce côté là parce que là je
voudrais voir si l'opposition elle est
sur le fond où elle est justement sur la
forme parce que sur le fond dans les
discussions générales bête tout le monde
s'est relevé un peu de la discussion de
comptoir donc l'un sur l'autre
sur le fond eh bien je pense que
pourraient montrer des vraies
différences qu'on avait sous le pied on
vous sent un patient le gouvernement le
1er mai ce qui vous a que très
clairement dit tenir
vous lui dit chiche jusqu'à quand vous
voulez au moins les trois semaines
prévues ben oui moi je devais tout c'est
déjà prévu de faire des procurations si
je devais être là pendant la période des
municipales donc jeu
c'est intéressant et le son de cloche de
la majorité qui dit finalement
gouvernement attendait pas de 49,3 tout
de suite elsa où on en est ce soir de ce
débat parlementaire est ce que ça avance
quand même un peu exactement monsieur le
rat border vous en parler on a voté
l'article 2 tout à l'heure dans
l'hémicycle c'est l'article qui instaure
un système universel et bien pour tout
le monde salariés du privé du public
professions libérales indépendant
agriculteur on a beaucoup discuté de la
situation des avocats la droite
notamment voulait les exclure du système
on attaque donc l'article 3 en a 65 ans
tous alors justement on a compris que
c'était une guerre d'usure qui se jouait
dans l'hémicycle finalement il n'y a pas
que les insoumis qui on prépare des
coups d'éclat qui veulent au fond faire
un peu de théâtre c'est ça exactement et
monsieur le premier ministre vous
parliez d'être créatif et bien c'est la
majorité hier qui a essayé de l'être
dans l'hémicycle alors vous parliez un
de ses amendements des communistes qui
voulaient reculer un an après 1 an
l'entrée dans le régime universel et
bien la république en marche a décidé de
ne pas rester dans l'hémicycle ils ont
demandé une suspension de séance et au
retour de la suspension écouter ce qu'a
proposé leur patron nous ne sommes pas
là pour entendre des amendements sans
aucun intérêt nous sommes là pour avoir
un débat de fond sur un texte essentiel
en conséquence le groupe la république
en marche restera représentée par son
président les autres membres quitteront
l'hémicycle et ne reviendront que
lorsqu'on sera en mesure de reprendre un
débat sain et apaisée et voilà les
députés donc de la république en marche
et du modem quittent l'hémicycle ça
c'est des images qu'on voit souvent à
l'assemblée mais normalement c'est
l'opposition donc ils quittent tous
l'hémicycle les uns après les autres en
faisant un peu de bruit on voit donc
après le président legendre et bien
qu'ils aient tout seul dans les travées
sur les bancs le débat reprend les
communistes défendre leurs amendements
alors les députés de la majorité ils
vont pas très très loin encore même ils
veulent pas se faire surprendre par un
vote dont il reste en bas de l'hémicycle
et puis ils remontent enfin et se
réinstalle ses députés bien il voulait
ne pas laisser les l'opposition de
gauche et bat décidé de tout ils ont
décidé de faire un coup politique
il les assume et il aime bien ils y
prennent goût finalement à faire un peu
de politique c'est sacha ollier député
de la vienne
qui a voulu justement faire ça on était
contents d'être là ça nous ressoude ce
genre de moment voilà il est envoyé
ils sont créés y avait pris goût aussi
une certaine forme de c'est pas de
l'obstruction là mais c'est des coups
d'éclat c'est on n'est pas content mons
horde de l'hémicycle ça fait partie
aussi j'ai extrêmement des choses à
faire quand on n'est pas député de la
majorité parce que pour moi en tant que
rapporteur je suis sollicité il faut que
je fasse attention à ce qui se dit pour
répondre à ce qu'ils aient mais les
députés de la majorité puisque les
amendements sont essentiellement portée
par l'opposition sont essentiellement
passif il faut qu'ils attendent et la
proportion de prise de parole pour eux
extrêmement faibles donc il ya un côté
là quand ils ont vu le tunnel
d'amendements 650 amendements signant
vaste sans pouvoir parler sans pouvoir
s'exprimer
donc il ya eu un moment de lassitude et
c'était l'occasion pour eux de 2,2 de se
ressouder de faire un acte politique par
le silence proportions le président du
groupe modem à l'assemblée patrick
mignola explique vous faites je parle
des la majorité un démarcheur assemblée
l'objet d' insulte hors micro c'est vrai
ça oui il ya mais il ya toujours ces des
attaques vous vous prenez il ya
quelqu'un qui parle il est attaqué sur
ce qu'ils limitent on va dire ça c'est
ça sa puce de je vais pas dire si
univoque ce système là il ya un certain
nombre de députés qui ont besoin de
s'exprimer et parce qu'il ya de la
tension parce qu'il ya de la fatigue il
ya il ya des noms d'oiseaux des mots qui
sont pas viables qui sont qui sont
lancés je dirais je vais pas toujours
citer les origines parce que ça peut
venir de tous les côtés ça ça arrive et
s'attend à l'atmosphère on le voit y
avait des moments de tension comme sur
un terrain de foot
figurez vous même si là on parle de la
forme il ya quand même un peu de débats
de fond à travers aussi les amendements
de l'opposition à travers vos
amendements verra ce qu'il en est
d'ailleurs je rappelle serre ça m'a
beaucoup étonné que en cas de 49,3 et
vous allez me corriger c'est la copie du
gouvernement c'est pas celle qui l'a
proposé mais il peut même intégré des
amendements qui n'ont pas été votées ces
pratiques
écoutez il ya une motion de censure si
la motion de censure parce le texte le
gouvernement tort peut-être même qu'avec
1 49 3 les amendements d'amélioration du
texte de la majorité seront prises en
compte
mais il est vrai pistes d'amélioration
c'est dommage de ne pas voir le débat
sur le fond parce que sur les
transitions par exemple sur la
solidarité il y avait des endroits
d'amélioration ou une partie de
l'opposition auraient pu participer
à construire quelque chose à améliorer
le texte alors on verra ça parce qu'il
manifestement il ya encore un petit peu
de jeu un petit peu de jours de débat
dans l'hémicycle figurez vous monsieur
le député vous savez certainement déjà
monsieur l'ancien premier ministre
eh bien on est très très petit joueur en
matière d' obstruction n'est ce pas
françois françois durpaire
ce sont les américains qui sont
champions à la matière oui et c'est la
pratique du filibuster ring alors ça
concerne pas la chambre des
représentants ça concerne que le sénat
ça consiste en quoi c'est très simple
deux choses à la française effectivement
c'est d'avoir le plus d'amendements
possibles il ya une deuxième pratique
très pratique et c'est le fait de ne pas
pouvoir interrompre un sénateur figurez
vous que dans les règles du sénat
ça ne se fait pas en interrompre à un
sénateur alors vous pouvez parler des
heures des heures et des heures pour
bien pour ralentir l'agenda
parlementaire qu'est ce que ça veut dire
filibustering c'est très simple c'est un
mot qu'on utilise depuis 1853 et en
français flibustiers voyez ce que c'est
ce sont les pirates du parlement les
corsaires du parlement et le premier bon
1853 y en a un très connus 1917 et la vo
ancêtres nicolas turquois il avait de
quoi s'inquiéter parce que c'était
l'entrée en guerre et 23 jours les
sénateurs ou les ralentir l'entrée en
guerre et pendant 23 jours et bien ils
ont ralenti cette loi qui permettait d'
armer les bâtiments américains on voit
beaucoup plus proche de nous 2013 voyez
les images là c'est ron paul
alors on voulait accélérer sa dure 13
heures pendant 13 heures ils
essaieraient ralentir 13 heures et
pendant très très réfléchie
arrêtez warin disais tout à l'heure 4h30
c'est beaucoup quand vous parlez pendant
13 heures un peu n'importe quoi raconter
par exemple dans les années 30
elle enquêtait sénateur de la lousiane
il récitait shakespeare réciter
shakespeare
et puis il avait aussi un livre de
recettes il tournait en boucle livre de
recettes
lui c'était son record 15 heures et ça
c'est à dire les années 1930 alors
est-ce que les américains ils vont à
49,3 pour arrêter l'obstruction ou pas
non alors ils ont pas de 49 3 mais ils
ont l'équivalent c'est la règle 22 1975
il décide que vraiment trop c'est trop
on peut pas comme ça laissait les
sénateurs débattent de mattia illimitée
donc ils décident cette règle qui
consiste et bien si vous avez deux tiers
des sénateurs tout simplement vous
pouvez interrompre le sénateur et il
faut 60 sénateurs
la conséquence est que aujourd'hui quand
vous êtes spécialiste des états unis et
que vous regardez les élections au sénat
vous vous dites ok les républicains ils
ont cinquante et une voix donc ils ont
la majorité mais vous regardez la super
majorité et la super majorité c'est à 60
il faut 60 pour pouvoir faire passer
tranquillement les projets de loi sinon
et bien on est parti pour des autres et
qui détient le record pour finir vous
avez commencé à nous en page
ah oui alors le record c'est le plus
récent c'est le 28 août 1957
c'est ce show man show menthe sénateur
de caroline du sud il s'opposer vous
savez toutes les mesures contre la
discrimination c'était fameux droits
civiques et lui il a tenu 24 heures et
18 minutes
pour la petite histoire la petite
anecdote il avait fait avant un bain de
vapeur pour un peu écoulé tous les excès
liquide à l'intérieur de son corps parce
qu'évidemment 24 heures et 18 minutes
vous voyez où je veux en venir
il faut aller aux toilettes bah oui mais
pendant 24 heures 18 minutes grâce à
cette préparation physique d'athlète de
haut niveau il a réussi à passionner 24
heures et devient un chapeau l'artiste
les nerfs il fait plaisir c'est de voir
le ton qui est aujourd'hui suite
monsieur tueur coin celui de cette
ambiance générale parce qu'au fond ce
qu'il faut c'est que le débat
parlementaire soit apaisée et que c'est
vrai que le 49 3 c'est pas une pratique
souhaitable email c'est une réponse une
obstruction à un moment devient
insupportable il fait qu'on déborde du
calendrier mais c'est vrai que l'idéal
d'un parlement aujourd'hui c'est quand
même l'expression du respect c'est ce
qu'on fait je crois en grande partie à
la parlement français pour terminer je
voulais vous faire réagir une autre
guérilla ya celle des retraites qui
s'est jouée qui se joue dans l'hémicycle
mais il ya une autre forme de bras de
fer à l'extérieur de la santé figurez
vous que les avocats vous en avez parlé
sont venus manifester devant les grilles
du palais bourbon il ne désarment pas
ils refusent toujours de basculer dans
le régime universel de retraite on voit
ça avec un reportage signé clément
perreault tourné à la fois à paris et à
bobigny merci à tous en grève depuis le
début de l'année les avocats étaient
aujourd'hui devant l'assemblée
ils dénoncent la fin de leur caisse
autonome prévue dans le projet de loi
retraites est comme ça fait huit
semaines que personne n'ose en temps on
se dit que peut-être on se rapproche des
gens qui sont en ce moment en train de
discuter notre avenir on sera peut-être
entendu pour une fois
agathe grenouille et plaident au barreau
de bobigny c'est le deuxième de france
en volume d'affaires traitées elle
perçoit la réforme des retraites comme
le coup de grâce pour une justice en
manque de moyens depuis plusieurs années
la seine saint denis est
particulièrement touchée par
l'engorgement judiciaire alors ça c'est
des dossiers qui sont en cours donc par
dossiers en cours on attend les dossiers
qui sont encore en enquête les dossiers
qui sont encore en instruction donc chez
un juge d'instruction va par exemple
c'est le dossier qui est censé être jugé
demain pour des faits qui datent de 2012
c'est extrêmement longtemps judiciaire
c'est extrêmement long pour tout le
monde ça pose aussi parfois la question
de l'intérêt de la compréhension d'une
peine qui est prononcée par fois en huit
ans après les faits pour cette affaire
comme pour les autres l'avocate va
demander un renvoi au motif de la grève
selon le parquet depuis le début de
l'année 40 % des audiences sont reportés
le tribunal de bobigny
les permanences des commis d'office ne
sont plus assurées les avocats assume
d'aller au bras de fer pour certains
c'est une question de survie
professionnelle avec un doublement des
cotisations comme c'est actuellement
prévus dans le projet doit donc de
passer de 14 % à 28 %
c'est des cabinets qui vont fermer parce
qu'ils ne vont pas pouvoir faire face à
ce doublement des cotisations et donc en
seine-saint-denis on estime à peu près
40% des cabinets d'avocats qui fermeront
à cause de cette répression huit
semaines pour démobiliser donc parfois
on va pas vous gâcher il ya des moments
de fatigue mais il y en a toujours des
confrères pour rebooster les troupes et
on est toujours motivé on a toujours des
actions quasiment quotidiennes
alors
[Applaudissements]
roh92 fils des mois
même si mac on ne peut pas nous on est
là
la ministre de la justice nicole
belloubet déplore ce mouvement de grève
qui selon elle porte atteinte au
fonctionnement de l'institution
judiciaire
c'est vrai que les avocats jean pierre
raffarin quand ils font grève
on a vu que ça bloquait quelques procès
mais c'est beaucoup moins spectaculaire
que grave dans l'est dans les transports
ou dans l'éducation nationale il
multiplie les coups d'éclat ils ont
beaucoup d'imagination d'ailleurs pour
pour se rendre visible il s'accroche
alors régime autonome vous ne comprenez
ou pas oui je les comprends bon je pense
je les comprends parce que je suis
vraiment favorable à la fin des régimes
spéciaux les régimes automnaux c'est une
autre affaire c'est leur argent ce donc
il y avait peut-être pas nécessiter de
tout remettre ensemble donc je crois de
toute façon dans ce texte une
clarification global sera nécessaire ya
un débat au sénat on viendra ya la
question du financement et les
observations du conseil d'état donc il
ya des choses il ya du travail à faire
c'est pour ça que si on veut un brin
débats parlementaires apaisés
il ya un vrai travail à faire sur ces
sujets là il faut être attentif à ce
qu'il dit je crois mais vous avez un des
buts est attentif sur sur ce plateau
vous savez que la grève des avocats a eu
raison du premier jour officiel du
procès fillon qui devait avoir lieu
lundi et qui est finalement ses tenues
pour son premier jour aujourd'hui au
palais de justice de paris vous en
attendez quelques choses franchement
écoutez cette injustice aujourd'hui de
dire ce qu'elle pense de cette affaire
je la fais est engagé sur la justice
laissons la justice décide et je veux
surtout pas intervenir on va on sait que
le calendrier était quand même plus
étonnant non gratae de l'avoir soutenu
jusqu'au bout non coûter cher
je regrette pas ce que j'ai fait je
pense que l'on dit est dans une
procédure on avait fait des élections
primaires mon candidat n'avait pas gagné
la primaire celui qui a gagné tout le
monde de le soutenir et on sent que
c'est un épisode encore donc j'ai de
cette douloureuse extraordinairement
douloureux les hommes de droite ou du
centre hadley les cicatrices sont
ouvertes en cas beaucoup de sujets là
c'est à la justice de décider
n'ajoutons pas de la politique à ce qui
est une affaire assez compliqué merci
infiniment jean pierre raffarin d'être
venu sur le plateau en direct sur le
plateau de lcp
merci à vous monsieur le député à la
semaine prochaine a très vite elle d'art
tous et à demain je vous le poitou très
belle soirée à vous
[Musique]